The Joe Rogan experience.
So you get the key from this guy's car,
right?
You can't use the APP.
Right.
So you,
you have to rely on the software in the state that it's out.
There is no software updates.
No.
So here's a,
here's a long story.
So get the car going.
Everything's great.
In order to get mask mask from the TUSLA system.
So there's a certain system that the Tesla knows we're all their cars are and
they could disable whatever they want.
They can do whatever they want.
They see now.
Exactly.
So I had to reach out to like this Tesla black hat hacker pretty much.
Oh Jesus.
You will go to the dark web.
I had to go to the deep dark web and um,
and he was able to mask Tulsa from seeing the car,
which is why can't have the Tesla App.
Oh.
So he matched that.
So he got into the actual software itself in the actual software.
Tell guys a genius is Phil switched one to zero.
Exactly.
It took a bit and then it was able to be,
uh,
the car could supercharge a car,
could do everything.
I can do.
And the car gets updates too.
It's great.
Oh,
it does.
It does get updates.
Yeah.
And Tesla doesn't know it's getting updates.
No.
You know what's funny?
We shouldn't say this.
I'm just kidding.
Now they,
they know the deal.
And here's,
here's the problem with that is that,
um,
people love these cars a lot.
Man That didn't love these cars,
you know,
hence me,
I'm picking the car like a dirty lake,
you know what I mean?
In fixing this thing,
So it's,
it's a lot of the times it's in their best interest,
I believe,
to help people out a little bit.
Um,
but,
but no,
the things that people go through for these cars is insane and people just,
they just love them.
My take on it is,
th what they have is this ingenious company with this mad genius scientist who's
running it,
who does a million other things at the same time.
And they don't have enough people to deal with someone like you.
They probably just don't,
they don't have like a section of the company to deal with someone like you.
They,
do you remember when he was working,
when he was,
they were trying to put out the model three and he was working 16 hours a day
and sleeping on the floor and the cabinetry.
Yeah,
pretty much shit that don't make any sense.
The people,
you know,
it's funny people,
it doesn't make any sense,
but people love the company.
They love this guy.
So,
so Cigna that um,
when he was working 16 hours a day,
uh,
and he was sleeping on the floor in the factory,
right.
You know,
it was a big sob story of billion years to be on the floor.
The factory,
a bunch of Tesla owners rallied together and they purchased a couch for him to
sleep on like tens of thousands of dollars.
What kind of couches they must than a nice ass count.
Crazy could be the way.
Like they,
they rallied and they purchased a couch for him and like I made a video on it.
I said to myself,
you know what?
This guy's a billionaire in B.
But the fact that everyone rallied together to help this guy to show that their
support people are hands over fist with this company.
Man,
they are heels.
It reminds me of apple back in the day.
Uh,
you know,
I remember there was a,
God,
God bless his heart who uh,
was one of the editors on news radio,
the a sitcom that was on the 90s and he was such an apple head that he was like,
he was talking about it like it was a sports team who's was talking about it.
Well I think we're really going to get those PC guys team when the MAC books
come out but keep it.
But he really said something to that all along those lines.
I think we're really gonna pull ahead.
Like who's we,
we meet users where they were on this weird little tribe.
Mac and this is the same thing,
but you know what?
You don't picture the apple fan boys at Tesla Fan boys times 10.
Yeah,
they live in it.
It's like an apple.
You live in,
it's times 10 Trevena working cause not because apple has a technology aspect of
it,
like it's great.
You know android socks,
I have an apple phone.
Okay,
perfect,
perfect.
But for Teslas,
you're talking about technology.
So you have a tech nerds,
you're talking about sustainability as well.
For the green people,
Greens,
you have the tech and the green people and once they joined forces the scariest
force on the earth.
Right.
It isn't like war,
like guns and stuff.
It's actually a Mac owning Tesla vegan owner.
Yeah.
It's the scariest thing in the way.
It really is a serious thing in the world because they'll tell you all about it
at a party.
Oh,
got it cornered.
They get corner.
But like they,
it and it's,
and I've struggled with that in a lot of cases because whenever I say something
remotely negative about Tessa,
like,
Hey,
I think Tesla could do a better job here.
They're just like,
you're just a gas head.
I know you own a zoo.
Six,
you work for big one.
So I want to QT working for big oil.
Oh you do?
Yeah.
What do you do for them?
How do you work for the coil?
What does that mean?
You work for big oil.
Yeah.
You A,
you're a part of the Illuminati.
Yeah,
pretty much.
That's like I just,
yeah.
You worked for big oil.
Well,
how do it for big oil?
What does that,
what does that mean?
How much could they pay you to,
first of all,
before people would realize it,
all of a sudden you're walking around with like diamond chains on shit.
Think it'd be moved to a giant mansion.
Right?
You still fixing cars?
Yeah.
Do you want for big oil?
You know,
I've got another thing going on.
Right?
Right.
Am I cutting billions for big oil?
Yeah.
By by a gas car.
Go to shell.
Shell's Great.
I don't understand how people think that the,
that whole shield thing works.
Did you just get like a monthly check?
I don't understand.
Like hey rich,
say something negative about Tufts.
Every once in a while we'll give you a check for 20 grand.
You got to get that big oil check.
I suspect that what it is is similar to what my friend who was really addicted
to apple.
Yeah.
I think you just get on your tribe.
And that's my thing.
I'm all about apple and as your camp windows or it's bullshit.
When this was bullshit,
what you want to play,
what are you going to fuck with the config files?
Get in there and then use dos.
Get outta here.
Yeah,
you lose it a loser.
But it's interesting because people like us are very different because we could
appreciate both.
You have a phenomenal collection of cars.
Thank you.
And um,
and then you threw a Tesla in there,
but you love both.
Like you love the driving.
You left the driving aspect of video of your Porsche.
You know,
you love,
you know,
the,
the silence and the,
the zero to 60 of your Tesla too.
So like you could,
we could be part of both camps,
but a lot of cases they're only,
it's camp Tesla.
And if you're not with us,
you're against us.